fox news alert 10 people killed in what
authorities are calling a racially
motivated attack in a new york state
supermarket the 18 year old suspect
now facing first degree murder charges
after police say he traveled hours to
the store in a predominantly black
neighborhood and live streamed the
rampage online
former acting dhs secretary chad wolfe
is here to react chad thank you for
being with us we'd love to get your
perspective on this as the investigation
moves forward this morning a ton of
evidence to sift through and i would
imagine federal investigators beginning
to become involved as well
well i think that's right i think what's
important here is we're in the early
stages of this of this incident and the
investigation so i think it's important
to let law enforcement do their job
i think it's it's only natural for
people to either jump to conclusions or
really try to understand the motivations
behind this but there's going to be a
lot of evidence at the scene there
should be a lot of evidence online in
other places we need to let police law
enforcement do their job and i think
we'll have some answers pretty soon i
want to move to the border chad with you
as well so there's an internal customs
and border protection document it's from
late last year and it apparently warned
that significant safety implications of
ending title 42 the public health order
would ensue if that were repealed uh it
also noted by the way that criminal
organizations control
huge parts of central america something
that we obviously know what does this
tell us i mean you know the takeaway
seems to be obvious the administration
knows the risk it's running here in
repealing title 42.
well they've known the risk that they're
running for the past 15 months when they
just are failing to do their job and
bringing some enforcement and some
deterrent into the system so the report
you mentioned but i can tell you
border patrol agents and officers have
talked to dhs leadership the political
leadership at the department dozens and
dozens of times and warning them about
the steps that they are taking they
warned them back in january of 2021
saying that if you tear down if you stop
building the wall if you tear down
remain in mexico and some of these other
measures you're going to have a surge in
a crisis like you've never seen before
and it's all coming true because these
are the men and women the border patrol
agents and officers that are down there
doing that job every day so
i've written about it i've talked about
it where political leadership is
ignoring their recommendations
and fulfilling an agenda that is more
political than it is protecting
americans each and every day and so
absolutely bringing down title 42 it's
the last tool in the tool belt if you're
a border patrol agent or officer it's
the only thing left that allows you to
do your job because the bite
administration has taken away everything
else so absolutely they are worried
about this you know i want to follow up
on this idea that it's political so let
me see if i'm reading you right title 42
which is there as a covid restriction a
coveted protection mechanism
on its surface on its face the time has
passed in other words for coveted safety
implications it's literally the only
thing
used to enforce our border so
when you say political if the bite
administration continues to enforce
title 42 in essence i guess that's an
admission
hey we need to do something to enforce
the border right i mean
the i i think we focus too much on title
42 it's a papered over
enforcement mechanism that should be
being done
anyway well you're absolutely right and
i think you you see a number of
democrats anywhere from a dozen or more
that are saying don't take down title 42
and i think their major concern is not
from a public health perspective their
major concern is it's the only thing
left keeping the border under control
any resemblance of control and i would
say it's not control but really from
having a breaking wide wide open and i
would say and i would agree with you
look title 42 has always been temporary
but what the bite administration should
do and they'll tell you that since uh
march of last year or sometime they're
up they've been planning for title 42 to
be removed what they actually should
have been doing is putting other
measures and other policies and other
procedures in place so that when title
42 is taken down there's other
enforcement mechanisms there's other
deterrents into the system that deters
this illegal behavior that we're seeing
up to 221 000 in the month of march
alone it's crazy these numbers are
absolutely ridiculous but it's because
there is no deterrent in the system the
byte administration has taken it all the
way and the last deterrent right now is
title 42.
yeah absolutely chad um yeah it's almost
like let's make title 42 separate from
kova the independent of kovit a true
enforcement mechanism for our border as
it remains in place okay chad thank you
for joining us this morning
thank you